okay in this video I'm gonna talk to you
about
antiseptics and I'm also going to talk
to you about antibiotics and the simple
differences between them so antiseptics
are used outside the body and
antibiotics are used inside the body so
that's one of the the distinct
differences and I'll come to talk about
this one in a second
and essentially antiseptics are used to
stop the the spread Kasbah spread of
infection
so they will kill bacteria so you might
use them to clean up a wind or you might
use them to as like a surface cleaner in
your house and they're not used to treat
a wound or illness but they're used to
really kill it and and stop it from
spreading
now antibiotics are different and
there's two types of antibiotics
there are antibacterials or
antibacterial antibiotics bacterials and
there's also antifungals now you can
probably guess which one's these treat
so antibacterials will treat a bacterial
infection and antifungals will treat a
fungal infection now something that's
really important about antibiotics they
and I'm going to do this in a different
color to make it really obvious they do
not treat
viral infections
okay and the way that they work is very
very similar they will basically
antibacterials you know do this another
color to make it obvious they will stop
bacteria from growing
something that's really important about
antibiotics is what they can do is they
can develop resistance and I'm going to
talk about bacterial resistance in
another video but but that's a really
important thing about using overuse of
antibiotics is they can develop
resistance and let's just go back to
finishing off talking about antifungals
and antifungals will will basically kill
the fungus and and also try and stop it
from from growing so you know remember
these are like your surface sprays that
you use to try and stop the spread of
infection and then antibiotics are used
inside the body and they will treat
bacterial or fungal infections and they
do that by trying to stop bacteria from
growing and and kill fungus and stop it
from growing